Look, I’m not an advocate of a political
violence even in virtuous causes, so I’m
not particularly a fan of the Anti-Fa or Black
Bloc or those things, but there is no moral
equivalence between neo-Nazis and people gathering
to oppose them.
There simply isn’t.
You can’t say that people standing up against
Nazism, white supremacy and racism are the
same as the people who are in fact white supremacist,
neo-Nazis and racists.
The moral equivalence doesn’t exist and
I think everyone, except the occupant of the
Oval Office, can see that.
And I’ve always thought that the great thing,
and I think this is exactly where [Richard]
Dawkins comes out, is that you have to make
a distinction between ideas and people, and
that it’s perfectly legitimate to express
even vehement dislike of ideas and of belief
systems, but it’s not acceptable to turn
that into bigotry against people who are part
of those belief systems.
So you have to protect the person but not
protect the ideology.
I think the nature of intellectual activity
is that ideas are up for discussion, and if
I don’t like your ideas it’s entirely
proper that I should say so.
But for me to treat you in a bigoted fashion
because I don’t agree with you is not acceptable.
So if you think the world is flat, and I think
you’re an idiot, it’s okay for me to say
that.
So I think we have to retain that ability
to be able to have open discourse about ideas
and not to become afraid that we’re offending
somebody, because actually the open, intellectual
discourse... it often offends people.
I remember once being invited to a lunch at
MIT, a rather humbling lunch because of the
kind of two dozen or so people around the
table maybe 20 of them had won the Nobel Prize.
And I was very interested the way in which
they talked to each other about each other’s
ideas—it was pretty much brutal.
They would call each other idiots and fools
for having certain scientific theories, I
mean the most frank language was being used.
I thought this is extraordinary; what are
these people going to say about each other
after lunch is over?
But actually the moment the lunch was over
it was obvious that they were on perfectly
good terms with each other and they had no
hard feelings, and they were perfectly willing
to have that kind of very abrasive interchange
without taking it personally, and I thought
that was really quite impressive.
To me that’s the kind of model of the intellectual
life: that you could be as abrasive as you
like at the level of ideas, but you don’t
make it personal.
I also do a bit of adverse writing [advertising?],
I do a bit of lecturing around the country
and I was not so long ago lecturing in Florida
in a town called Vero Beach, which is near
Cape Canaveral, and the audience was older,
it was very white, it was very conservative,
and I would’ve said a very large majority
of them had probably voted for Trump.
I have to say they were very civil, very courteous,
they heard me out, nobody booed or threw things
or walked out—it was a civilized encounter,
but there were very strong disagreements.
So in the Q&A, for example, I had said something
in my remarks about climate change and a gentleman
at the microphone said how I was completely
wrong because when I said that all these scientists
basically supported my views on climate change
that wasn’t right, and then we got into
a kind of “yes it is, no it isn’t” thing.
And I tried to say to him that if you think
the world is flat it doesn’t make the world
flat, the world doesn’t need you to believe
that it’s round to be round because there’s
what we call evidence that shows us what shape
the world is.
And I said it seems to be the same is true
of climate change.
So we had this kind of—I mean there was
another gentleman who basically said, “How
can you believe that the New York Times isn’t
just lying to you everyday?”
So in a way I was actually quite encouraged
by the conversation because it was extremely
frank, but it was also within the bounds of
civilized conversation, so it was opposite
sides actually talking to each other.
And I thought, “Well, maybe it’s a good
idea to do more of that.”